[Music]
you notice shortness of breath and a
stark pain in your chest you might have
lost your taste and smell and your
breathing like you just walked up three
flights of stairs these symptoms signal
a trip to the emergency department of
your local hospital how will you be
treated when would you be put on a
ventilator and how could you develop a
severe case of kovat 19
despite being perfectly healthy this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you were hospitalized with kovat 19
before you rush in call your doctor or
hospital ahead of time and describe your
symptoms you'll want to do this because
your local emergency clinic might not
have enough beds and may need to direct
you to another facility or your symptoms
might not be considered severe enough
yet to require treatment at the hospital
so it's best to check by phone first but
once you are admitted nurses will give
you a kovat 19 test most patients will
also have a set of blood tests taken
from their veins doctors will then
listen to your lungs and check the
levels of oxygen in your blood with a
clip-on finger monitor why are they
doing that because if you have severe
kovat 19 symptoms the oxygen levels in
your blood can drop too low since this
can result in life threatening damage to
your vital organs
you'll get oxygen to breathe through two
small tubes that go just inside your
nostrils or through a facemask you'll
then get a chest x-ray or a CT scan so
that doctors can get a better
understanding of which areas of your
lungs are inflamed a CT scan also known
as a computerized axial tomography is a
painless diagnostic test that uses
x-rays and computers to create
cross-sectional images of your body a CT
scanner is a large square or round x-ray
machine with a tunnel through the center
it helps doctors see into your lungs
during your CT scan you will lie on a
table that slow
passes through the tunnel a giant ring
called a gantry will rotate around your
body it contains a tube that releases
x-ray beams and detectors that will
measure the amount of radiation absorbed
by your body and these beams will
capture many views of your body from
different angles as the gantry spins the
detectors will send data to a computer
that creates cross-sectional images or
3d models of your lungs helping doctors
diagnose the severity of your
coronavirus infection once your doctors
have all the data to determine the
progress of your kovat 19 infection what
treatments can improve your condition
well some patients may get standard
antibiotics these won't fight the
coronavirus directly but could be
beneficial if you develop an additional
bacterial infection in your lungs but
because there is no approved medicine
specifically for kovat 19 you'll be
relying on your immune system to fight
off the virus and hope that oxygen
therapy combined with supportive care
can help your body recover if things go
your way your immune system will start
to produce antibodies to slowly kill the
virus but what happens if your condition
worsens in that case you will probably
experience severe breathing problems
high fever profound headaches and nausea
if the oxygen concentration in your
blood then drops below critical levels
doctors can escalate your treatment to
something called high flow nasal oxygen
which means that a machine will be
pushing air into your nose warmed to
body temperature and humidified with
sterile fluid you can get up to 60
liters of oxygen per minute and up to
100% concentration there are concerns
however that this can put viruses into
the air and potentially infect other
patients caregivers or anyone nearby to
counter this risk
hospitals have negative pressure rooms
these are isolation rooms equipped with
a special ventilation system that
generates negative pressure by allowing
air to flow in but not to leave the room
the air is then ventilated to the
outdoors through a filter system the bad
news is that not every hospital has
these rooms
if high flow nasal oxygen is not an
option or didn't help doctors will start
you on mechanical ventilation in a last
life-saving effort you will be given
medication via IV to put you to sleep
the first step in mechanical ventilation
is called endotracheal intubation once
you're asleep your doctor will use an
instrument called a laryngoscope this
device helps guide the endotracheal tube
to its proper position your doctor will
tilt your head back slightly and insert
the laryngoscope through your mouth and
down into your throat taking special
care to avoid contact with your teeth
using a special blade on the device your
doctor will gently raise the epiglottis
which is a flap of tissue protecting
your larynx as they advance the tip of
the endotracheal tube into the trachea
once the tube is in place your doctor
will inflate a small balloon surrounding
the tube to make sure it remains snugly
in place they will then remove the
laryngoscope and tape the tube to the
corner of your mouth to prevent it from
being jostled out of position your
doctor will check to see that the tube
is properly positioned in the lower part
of the windpipe by inflating your lungs
with a special bag and listening for
breathing sounds on both sides of your
chest if the end of the tube is too low
both lungs will not receive the same
amount of air in some cases an x-ray is
taken immediately after intubation to
confirm the placement of the tube once
the endotracheal tube is in the proper
position your doctor will attach it to
the mechanical ventilator which will
have a specially designed pump that aids
respiration by delivering well
oxygenated air into the lungs and
permitting carbon dioxide to escape
levels of oxygen and carbon dioxide will
be closely monitored to confirm that the
ventilator is working properly so now
you're asleep and a machine is managing
your breathing what are your chances of
survival at this stage unfortunately
according to infectious disease expert
dr. Dennis Carroll former head of the US
Agency for International development's
emerging pandemic threats program only
around one third of those kovat 19
patients placed on ventilators survive
ventilators could also be damaging to a
patient when used over long periods of
time so if you do make it through this
you will have a long road of recovery in
front of you at the beginning of the
outbreak some hospitals were putting
patients on ventilators early on in
their treatment this was due in part to
concerns that less invasive ventilation
procedures could cause viral particles
to disperse into the air with more cases
of kovat 19-2 study health professionals
are attempting to set guidelines for
different types of respiratory failure
and who ventilator treatment would be
best suited for this includes
recommendations such as placing patients
on their stomach
called prone positioning which evidence
suggests helps increase the amount of
oxygen that's getting to their lungs so
with all this in mind why does this
virus cause only mild disease in most
people but could turn fatal for you
despite being healthy in such a case it
seems the worst damage may be caused by
an abnormal immune response to the
infection rather than by the virus
itself in simplified terms when any cell
in your body senses that there is
something foreign in this case a virus
the immediate response of the cell is to
kill itself a protective mechanism to
prevent it from spreading to other cells
the way this happens is that cells in
your immune system called macrophages
release small signaling proteins called
cytokines certain kinds of these trigger
cell death when many cells are doing
this at the same time a lot of tissue
can die this is what medical
professionals call a cytokine storm in
kovat 19 this means that lung tissue
breaks down and the walls of the lungs
tiny air sacs leak fluid through causing
pneumonia and starving the blood of
oxygen most of your cells in the tissue
will die as a result of this
uncontrolled level of cytokines it eats
away at your lungs to a point where they
cannot recover your body is now
attacking itself cytokine storms are
becoming a common occurrence in kovat 19
patients with severe symptoms and they
seem to play a role in death in a large
number of cases whether you would
develop a cytokine storm may depend on
genetic factors patients in studies with
the h1n1 influenza virus who developed
cytokine storm syndrome often possessed
subtle genetic immune defects resulting
in the uncontrolled immune response now
you are more likely to have developed
these genetic immune defects as you age
but there is also a small chance that
you might have a genetic predisposition
to developing cytokine storms after
infection with the novel coronavirus
it's important to mention that the
complete picture of cytokine storms is
not yet well understood and the medical
community is still early in
understanding the many aspects of the
disease a lot of findings and hypotheses
need to be confirmed in more and larger
clinical studies but the good news is
that many clinical trials are underway
to explore treatments used for other
conditions that could halt cytokine
storms and fight kovat 19 as well as to
develop new ones
there are currently hundreds of clinical
trials of proposed kovat 19 drugs
already recruiting patients so if you're
lucky enough and make it through all
this you'll be weaned off the ventilator
you'll probably feel extremely exhausted
but you can now step down from critical
care to a normal hospital ward where
you'll stay until you can maintain safe
oxygen levels by just breathing air
after that you can be discharged go home
and be reunited with your loved ones I
hope that going through a possible
hospitalization with kovat 19 will make
you understand why we need to be careful
kovat 19 is affecting not only people's
health but every aspect of our lives how
could you survive if the economy
collapsed completely well that's a story
for another what-if
one more thing special thanks again to
nucleus medical media for providing
these incredible 3d animations if you
want to watch more scientifically
accurate medical visuals check out their
channel linked in the description below